this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
ladies and gentlemen uh the spirit meter
just had red hot it just hit red hot
because we have uh Jonathan Mark who is
a medium and if you've uh if you're into
the medium world you would know who he
is which I am I just heard you got a
reading I did a reading before this and
you came out with your eyes a little red
yeah a little bit now that's that's
cheers so let me just say this again
Jonathan said you want to do a reading
he went into a room I wasn't allowed
there and Brennan came out with his eyes
all a red so either they were smoking
weeds or Johnson Mark got into some got
into some deep
stuff about the people Brandon loved who
are no longer with us am I right about
that and when he does it he he like
stares you know so he's not looking in
the face he's channeling and he was like
because I don't have too much death in
my family I'm both uh both Grandma's
dead Grandpa's dead so I figured be like
you know like my grandma he didn't say
he didn't say say goodbye to Brian
because this is the last day on Earth
he's like tomorrow Brian's gonna pass
away and I just I'm just like you know
John yeah
you know what he did say he was tell
Brian not to go to that weird place in
Chicago the theater not yet
no one's going to be there on Sunday
where everybody he called it he called
it okay but uh no yeah but he was like
I'm getting a lot of that's not medium
that's called Common Sense yeah yeah
true if he's a medium then I'll meet him
because I said that to you that's right
no but that's right he goes there's a
lot of people come through even Rogan
goes that's an off Market yeah but uh
seems like there's a lot of people who
come through he's like a guy that starts
with a K that you fought with and am I
I'm like I thought he keeps showing you
guys like fighting I'm like I'm like no
I don't know anybody that died Kimbo
yeah Kimbo came through he just said it
was unexpected like a relationship that
was sweet he's like all right well I
have a loud guy here and he's dressed
like a bodybuilder and I was like uh you
know starts with a P I'm like Pax my
uncle Pax he's like yup Pax is here so
the majority of it was packs and just
saying how like he's so proud of me and
like everything I built and
um also how like he's like I know you
went through a really tough time and you
keep your head down just what you're
doing you get you're on the other end of
this where I'm so proud of you like most
people with fold up shop and tell Brian
same thing I know he went through a
tough time tell him you guys doing the
right thing and I'm telling you guys are
on the other end of it keep doing what
you're doing it's going to pay off
come on man it was crazy dude I like
that kind of music I know I was like oh
man I'm glad he didn't go this is just
the beginning and or what if he's like
and you won't be coming out of it I
don't see a light at the end of your
tunnel or what if he was like Jungle
Pack says you're working too much it's
it's not going to pay off just yeah
it says stop yeah yeah shut down oh wow
he says shut down everything now save
all your money if you thought yesterday
was dark I'm seeing uh
uh a lump a girl a tumor I'm seeing a
tube but that's when I tell you have a
tumor no no I'm seeing don't bother
it was insane though dude insane that's
pretty cool wait describe Uncle Pax and
just like when did you uh start getting
this thing so when I was a kid my um
aunt passed away when I was about six
months old so I didn't really know her
other than like the pictures on the wall
that my family would have in my ad
because my mom and her were like best
friends and they like lived together
until they were like 30 years old
and when I was about four we're at
Easter and my grandfather who was still
living
I just walked up to him and I was like
talking with my family being a kid
whatever and I said Susie's here my mom
and my grandpa's like uh yeah whatever
like that's cool you know there's
pictures yeah yeah like we talk about
her literally every day because she
passed tragically and
then I was like she's grabbing a jacket
and like squeezing like a jean jacket
because I kept pointing at my pants and
I go I kept pointing and squeezing my
jacket and my grandpa's like what the
hell are you talking about and my mom
just starts like pouring tears just like
crying and EV so my other Aunt her other
sister's like why is she crying about
that so then when my mom collected
herself she walked back in she goes when
everyone left like the service the
funeral
my mom and her live together like I said
until they're 30 and there was a jean
jacket that they would steal back and
forth from each other like every day so
when they all left my mom walked back in
where the coffin was and put the jacket
on her so she was warm and she was
buried and she didn't tell anyone
because she didn't want anyone to know
that she walked back in that she did
this and then at that point my family's
like this is freaking weird like this
kid is like weird like what's going on
and then it just I was saying other
things about my family that you wouldn't
know I wouldn't know and I wish I never
did no type of thing like there were
some like really dark stuff that always
is in a family yeah that I found out
about like my grandfather and my aunt
that happened like the worst things that
could happen that she never told my like
things like that with like my family so
being a kid and saying it and bringing
that stuff to light was like a really
hard thing for my family to like process
and go through because you kind of
dredged it up yeah I literally because I
didn't know what it what were you doing
getting images of it yeah so I would see
some like the worst thing that a guy
could do to a young female like I saw
that with family members oh wow and I
and I said that I said like oh and I was
saying about touching and like like kind
of just like grabbing on like you're
like why doesn't Jonathan want to sit on
Grandpa's yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
lucky I meet him in 2023 man like when
you're a kid because they would medicate
you like this kid yeah yeah ain't that
the truth yeah so it just got insane
gift to have man I think what also crazy
about him I don't know how much you can
talk about yeah but he works with like
the FBI yep do you yeah yeah that's
interesting because I'll tell you my my
FBI story about it I want to hear what
you have to say though about okay uh no
just because a lot of times in the
Behavioral Science unit I always tell
the story there was a guy who was uh uh
I think he was Consulting on NCIS or
some show like that and he was like a
serial killer uh you know
and I said something to the effect of do
you guys use psychics and he looked man
he goes I'm a psychic and I went huh and
he goes he goes I'm not a psychic but I
can tell you things about uh he'd known
me for 40 minutes he goes I can tell you
stuff about your you right now that
you'd be like holy [__] right I said
whatever tell you the story and he goes
He I said like what and he goes is you
my guess is your dad's a big guy he's
probably from the Midwest I'm gonna
guess Wisconsin and uh and you admire
him very much and I went what the [__]
is going on you know what he said he
goes your voice tells me everything
you're you grew up listening to him
speak so you have a glottal stop there's
something about where I place my soft
palate oh really so I grew up trying to
copy him and then he just made this
assumption that apparently I make my
voice deeper than it is because I was
around men right so I guess I was doing
that but he could pick up on the fact
that I was lowering my voice that's
crazy and he said that's a kid who grew
up trying to emulate his dad who had a
big cavity he's a bigger guy oh wow so
you can make these deductions and I was
like dude that's crazy that's a gift in
itself yeah yeah but that's also
somebody who studied how to read
Behavior speech patterns that's you know
so every region has a different place
where you place your birth for him like
correct me if I'm running that remember
that girl Gabby is this right potato
yeah yeah married her boyfriend they're
on a road trip got murdered yeah they're
looking for the boyfriend in my research
looking up they came to them and weren't
you like stopped looking for him he's
dead when you say they came to you who
what's the specific agent or was it the
department like it was a specific agent
at the time at a loss and like so like I
always tell people this and it's the
truth that I'm the like Last Resort I'm
never there first of course like like
you know option and at that point they
came to me because I've done stuff with
them prior so they're like let's just
see like what this could be because
she's originally from Long Island and
they came to me and and I met them
through the Long Island serial killer
case because I started that in like 2017
with them yeah with their first task
force were you helpful yes yeah really
yep otherwise they wouldn't go back to
them yeah yeah what sense can you talk
about it yeah I could talk a little bit
about it um so in the beginning
they came to me and how how that started
was and I won't even like really like
fabricate this or anything I read the
wife and the wife's like listen you guys
are like screwed like just go to this
kid and see what he can do and like
that's how it started so you read which
what the wife of the serial killer of
the lead agent oh I'm sorry of the task
force and he came to me all he did was
he called me on my phone he goes you
have 15 minutes tell me what you got
that's literally what he did he goes you
15 minutes tell me what you got I told
him
there's an unusual R name because I
never like I didn't like put together
like Rex as like a name I would see like
Ryan Rob or whatever but I would never
picture like a Rex right and then I kept
talking about you know Burke and how and
like spoda and all these people and he
all I heard was he laughed and hung up
the phone
two weeks go by he calls me goes do you
want to be involved in this case and I
was like and I was like sure and he's
like all right you have an hour for
sending you a phone call he goes you're
gonna read one of the families like one
of the
um families that
the daughters were killed um like the
prostitutes and then it just started
escalating and then all of a sudden
because I'm sure people know about Burke
and all that since he was the chief of
police at that time that's right he kept
pocketing the case so every time we
would get somewhere he would pocket the
case so then he would was that because
he was also soliciting prostitutes yeah
he didn't want them to look into it
because he was doing the same stuff yeah
so that's why when they got the cadaver
dogs he goes ah they can't do in the
winter let's save it to give him more
time I'm like that didn't make sense
yeah and there's and then there's like
another murder case that even dates back
when they were kids that involves like
Burke and spoda together that they're
linking to yeah there's a kid on Long
Island
um there was a group of kids that shoved
rocks and leaves down the kids throw
they're like bullying him and the kid
like suffocated and died it was terrible
and they were like there because they
were friends like like the way that
Burke got to to be a chief was a little
shaky people say because it takes years
and years and years to get to that level
being chief of police of course and he
bumped it pretty fast
hey guys hey do you have you heard of
Area 51 yeah have you heard of area 15
no well dude November 2nd through the
5th our boy Aubry Marcus that's right it
is a beautiful music festival for all
you friends out there featuring
Headliners with my faves Chromeo Chromeo
oh I love Dr fresh elderbrook Jai Wolf
The Glitch Mob Troy boy yeah but Chromeo
Is My Jam my kiddos love their songs too
our boy Aubry Marcus is hosting this
incredible event it's a magic virtual
and it's selling out dude you have
Chromeo there all you got to do is go to
fitforservice.com
a-r-k-a-d-i-a right now again that's
fit4service.com
Arcadia and you can see Chromeo live the
headliners it's a celebration Beauty and
music and anything is possible human
expression Area 15 not to be confused
with Area 51 where the aliens are at and
we know it for a fact don't we that's
right that's a-r-k-a-d-i
a fitforservice.com Arcadia so I
interrupted your story though so so
about Gabby yeah about Gabby yes so no
I'm sorry the serial didn't he say you
have you have an hour now
oh yeah so he said I have like 30
minutes essentially okay so it went from
15 to 30 and they don't want from what
I've learned with them it's like there's
no like [__] like I have to do my
thing and then they hang up and leave
like I can't even like
like really get into like stuff like if
I want to talk to them like let's say
like I want to be like what happened
with it so I I do that and then the task
force gets canceled because Burke was
shelfing it so the first task force and
then Ray Tierney comes on the new D.A
and then when Bert got arrested for
um I think he like mishandled like
evidence because he brought someone in
like beat the [__] out of them and one
of the presets Shady dude yeah he's he's
a gross guy a new task force came and
because they used my recordings from
2017 they brought me back on to here and
then back in February time I get a call
from one of them and they're like we're
pacing this dude for about almost a year
now this guy Rex and they're like we're
waiting for two more things to come
through and then when they come through
we're gonna make an arrest
hangs up the phone haven't heard from
them and then I get a call the night
before they arrest him we're making the
arrest hangs up the phone and then my
phone gets blown up by like the people I
worked with on the first task force to
the other people and there was a little
Clues you gave them it's always some of
them I I feel like I was a small piece
to a large puzzle if I'm being honest
and I they got the DNA they got all that
stuff it was just they needed that
concrete evidence and now because of
that and I'm sure people know they're
linking bodies to this guy Rex from like
the 70s not in Seattle right
South Carolina yeah yeah there's a true
monster he's an actual monster because
like this dude I probably walked near
him on Long Island because I go to
Massapequa all the time and I didn't
even know and there's a picture of me
which is like even more weird when I was
a kid my grandfather lived three houses
away from Rex like his dad because his
dad his dad Rex bought his dad's house
that's why he looks like such a piece of
crap he never changed it from like
like so long ago and there's a picture
of me with my grandfather like you know
when I was a kid I used to jump in the
leaves and stuff and behind it you see
that red gross house and it was Rex's
House he's a giant too scary like huge I
heard some I heard some weird stuff
about him when when like the people made
the arrest like my friends transported
him that he was like ripping ass in the
car trying to like [__] with them and
then he was trying to be like sorry then
like [__] with them he's a gross
looking Dude too so gross yeah and and
do we know he would what would he do
just kidnap them and and kill him he
would just like essentially go to these
sex parties where like they like Burke
and all them were at oh he was was he so
he probably they're connecting them
together yeah that that Sheriff's group
yeah so he would essentially that's why
that guy was shelfing us because he
knows he's tied to it yeah and plus like
Burke also had sex with those girls and
then Rex would have sex with him after
yes and then kill him so like they were
tied within like a night period so
clearly he knew his buddy was killing
him I don't know if he knew right so
that's that's the part that like they're
trying to figure out is if they knew
because like Rex isn't saying anything
but Rex is admitting to my knowledge a
whole lot of stuff that's gonna come out
like on the trial and everything I mean
he might have I would imagine he
suspected when these girls started dying
he had to have been able to make that
connection
and then you hooked up with a young lady
and then you recommended your buddy and
then a month goes by like man I'd like
to see Katie again like Katie died yeah
that's weird all right what about
Tiffany Tiffany also does yeah all right
what about Mary Mary so these girls were
all coming from the same agency or they
were coming from the same area they're
prostitutes yeah they're coming from
Craigslist so they would go to
Craigslist and the last girl that they
have is that kind of was also like a
nail in the coffin for him they the call
logs was with him and she was walking
out of the hotel and you see like she's
like stumbling on her feet because there
was a doctor that was also involved in
this too who'd give them like anesthesia
stuff to like kind of [__] them up and
she she was like stumbling out like
stumbling the words and you see it from
the Long Island like there's like a
Hilton or something yeah and you see it
from the camera and then all of a sudden
she's dead that night like that was the
last time that they were seen it's
terrible so yeah where was he killing
them in his car
so different places right different
places he had an underground bunker
underneath his house he did yeah they
discovered like 200 guns and like a
soundproof room underneath his
background that he was doing whatever
yes yeah and they didn't discover that
for a while yeah did they actually raid
his house and then they found the
dungeon yeah yeah you can imagine what
he was doing to those poor girls it's so
sad it's so sad and will you get vision
of like the act that he did or no I got
I got visions of how he did it have
realized the crown my mind yeah and like
to me they were like that's like
insignificant to like what we need
they're like we know he killed them
they're like we just need to know like
where when and like kind of why they're
like we don't need to know like like
exactly how he did it because they know
yeah exactly they're like we know and
they found the wife's like hair on like
a couple of us yes too like they told me
was he strangling them or what was it
yeah
man I tell you yeah for my knowledge
bring him up to an horrible looking dude
yeah I mean like if he gave me a a
lineup of 100 people like oh that guy's
a series so so my I believe some people
need to be stoned I agree look at his
face like I don't
quickly I
because he had a green uh Chevy
Avalanche and they knew it and they
report it to the sergeant and he would
just keep putting it away he was so
cocky he would park it on the street and
it'd be so easy yeah to go find his car
and they just never did it he is a big
boy he's he's six six I think something
like he's he's large yeah and they and
like everyone knows about like the pizza
crust thing that they got yeah the DNA
on the pizza crust yeah they were like
pacing him for so long and they're like
trying to get one more evidence he just
threw that pizza cross and then you see
like a detective just Sprint grab it and
run and that's crazy all that time she's
nuts so you get a call from you do you
you work on this and then the same
agents call you about Gabby potato
different right they were different
because you because we were involved
with um Wyoming Utah and Florida so
there was three different cops yeah
there was different cops and different
ages but still FBI still FBI
yep and you know when they called me I
basically told them which then they were
like okay like let's work with him more
on this they thought she was still alive
and I said it's not a search and like
rescue it's a search and recover is what
you're doing because I'm like if I'm
reading one of the family members
actually when I was reading the mom
because now I'm allowed to talk about it
with her when I was reading her I was
basically saying I was like if she's
coming through to me like she's dead and
I'm like did you tell the mom that yeah
look I said it in like a way softer way
because I was like it was a bummer yeah
it was really tough and
you know and then they're like okay like
where do you see her and I was like
trying to describe didn't hear it then a
week goes by they're like yeah you're
right about the time because I said
she's been dead for like a couple weeks
at that point or like a week at that
point and they're like no way like she's
alive I'm sure you can get how there's
some pushback like those of course those
hardcore like tough nose yeah
well they have to be that way because
they did hard cold evidence no yeah I'm
assuming you get compensated for helping
them out I don't take the money yeah I
don't have any to do it I just want to
do it yeah I yeah and they deal you know
those guys who you've had contact with
they must deal with the darkest of
humanity so yeah and that's why like I
also have like empathy towards them too
because I feel like tough gig yeah like
if I can alleviate some of that Darkness
on them and help them out with them yeah
man I'm like it's just you know it's a
good thing for me are you religious
no not I'm not like overly religious I
definitely have faith but I'm not like
religious religion how many I'm sure now
because you've helped with these high
profile cases you have more precincts
reaching out like more districts I'm
sure yeah so I have about you know our
you know entrees my manager and we were
doing something and I have about over a
thousand cases from different law
enforcement we've got a lot of work to
do yeah a lot and I've been trying and
it's it's tough because when I take on a
case it's not just like a one two three
thing people think like it's not just
one reading and you're done and good it
could take me up to like the guild like
it took me like five years like it took
me takes time it takes time because they
have to go through the evidence I can't
do that what are you doing when you have
it like so what do you have to focus on
something specific with Gilgo what are
you doing with that like as far as like
the evidence you have to talk to their
family is that what you yeah so I talked
to the victims family yeah so so like
that's how I get different perspectives
like when it comes to how people pass
and what happened leading up to it and
everything because like those girls
didn't know each other like they were
not connected they were just
unfortunately girls that were on
Craigslist but they were not connected
to each other and they think this guy's
connected to the these are patterns 100
people these are these people that do
these things that's why they're called a
series yeah but any the criminals in
general rapists and right thieves and
right it's not the first time they're
doing this can't we connect to Jimmy
Hoffa's family for God's sake
just cracked the case
yeah here's the guy to do it back in the
day they didn't talk so but they're
family now yeah but the spirits will
come back and yeah and like taught me
yeah but we won't talk to you about
something yeah things yeah and then a
couple things with your mouth and the
the medium got really big because that
that kid who was on e oh Tyler yeah
Tyler would was big I think when it's
forced like that at first I was into I
like the medium stuff right like my
mom's really into it so I was really
into that Tyler's show but then I was
like all right this is whatever 48
episodes like I don't know man right and
it seems like you know then some of them
then I had my doubts yeah some of the
mediums crossing over that guy's a fraud
which one is that one hey you put him he
he literally they had a microphone in
the waiting room really yes in the
waiting room so people would be talking
and he'd be listening that [__] guy
but you know what people like go bad on
John Edward for me it's like the guy's
getting paid to have people look him up
I mean like I'm not I'm I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna give him a hard time if
it's like you just did you call him a
[__] idiot well well I I didn't mean
it that way I I bet they did a special
way apparently he has microphones in the
waiting room
and it's like he was he was hearing
things and but but at the end of the day
if people want to give him their money
and he's telling me and he makes them
feel good
I'm not going to say anything right how
do you feel about those guys I guess you
don't really know them so you don't pay
attention it sounds like you're not
really into the hole yeah you do your
own thing I do my own thing that's I
kind of Stay in My Own Lane because I
know there's you know like Teresa too
all those different ones that have their
like people have their views on them so
I'd rather I personally would rather
just stay in my own lane do my thing and
kind of um
I don't know like just do like the law
enforcement stuff I mean actually help
people yeah
like when she's reading the Kardashians
I'm like Oh Nicole you know it's gonna
come through there's nothing to go yeah
this is just for sure I'm out do you
ever see uh Sylvia Brown she was really
famous I heard about it she charged
seven hundred dollars for uh five
minutes on the phone or something crazy
yeah she made a fortune that was that
wasn't even worse she made a lot of her
money oh my God and so Sylvia Brown's on
uh she was on uh who's the remember the
black guy with the bald head uh what was
his what was it Montel I think it was
Montel and the girls like you know so
she's she's looking she's talking and
she goes your husband died underwater he
was in a van underwater I'm seeing and
and the girl goes but he was killed in 9
11. and I was like well I'm getting
water that's what I'm just telling you
like maybe somebody else maybe the
sprinklers you know from the fire huh it
was okay dude yeah she wasn't such a I
I've heard of her just from like I guess
yes she was before my time of stuff
they went bad on her and uh
but again it's like
people are willing to pay her for it
yeah
but they're not working like the FBI and
stuff like that like we don't want to
draw conclusions that you're like those
people it's just people I'm not I'm
asking them how you feel about it
because oh we just keep pointing out
horrible media yeah
I'm just saying he's like what else no
but have you ever gone to a psychic so
I've tried and they
say that they can't read me they say
really yeah I've haven't gone to one
that can read me that's interesting yeah
not one and I would change my name like
everyone does for me really like yeah
I'll change my name I'd wear a hat like
you know because the medium Community
it's like a small community right it's
like once you start like getting
contraction yeah they start seeing like
you know you and stuff so maybe they're
afraid to I don't know what it is they
they're like I'm not getting anything
like you're too like one of them said I
was too like intimidating because like I
try to get really specific and try to
get like all that stuff and some of them
are not obviously like that but they get
too like intimidated I guess I I don't
know I would love a reading honestly so
like I would love to hear some from some
people but not one has been able to read
me do you get mostly people I guess from
all over that come to you the uh and you
do it on online or do you do it yeah so
my clientele which I'm super fortunate
and thankful for is worldwide so I read
people from like pretty much any every
country I've read someone from and yeah
it's all done through like Zoom now
because I I used to have them come to my
house and then eventually like when you
know things started happening I was like
I don't want people walking in my house
anymore like because people are crazy
yeah but can you you get the same read
from someone over zoom and yeah rather
than person yeah it's the same thing I
mean it's just more intimate when you're
in person like it's a lot more personal
and like intimate versus like a computer
screen where it seems pretty
transactional when I come on I do my
thing it's like all right bye and I hang
up and then we're done a lot of times
when you're with people in person you
get that like connection of like you
know you're being with them you're
hanging out with them after they're
talking to you after versus like all
right see ya look at click and then it's
done and so
I just don't want people walking in my
house anymore that's like the biggest
thing for me like I'm I've had a couple
like horrible experiences with people
sure and it's they like threaten my
family and stuff and it's not even from
like the reading per se it's more so
like I would do the reading and they'd
want more and more and you're like I'm
not getting anything yeah and I'm like
I'm tapped out like this drains the crap
out of me like I'm pouring sweat that's
why I wear a sweatshirt
um I get migraines and stuff and they
want more and then they go nuts like
nuts and then that's when I'm like no
more okay you don't want that in your
house yeah I don't want that now are you
do you want to go down the same path as
some of these other you know mediums
that Brian brought up that go into the
Hollywood part of it like TV shows or
you got to answer date here I know
Anthony he's trying to pitch you to eat
right now
um I would probably say if like I would
do something it would have to be it
would have to be authentic and helpful
it can't be something where it's like I
don't know like who I'm walking into or
whatever like it would have to be where
I'm helping like a family with like a
case see I I think there could be
something sweet and new there actually
with him helping out like legit like
detectives and you know that's the move
yeah so we I'm sure you're already on it
but it was like a few like yeah sorry to
give away your idea but like Unsolved
Mysteries and like the guildo beach all
that stuff dude home run yeah I've I've
been like I've been trying to wait for
the like I guess we've been trying to
wait for the right moment with it and I
guess with this economy and this strike
and all that well you found executive
producer yeah yeah
how bad do you want to catch the person
that's all I say and do you ever meet
somebody where you're not doing a
reading have you ever met somebody and
gotten Vibes yeah so I've had like both
sides of like the experience of like you
know I would go off them and say
something and their reaction was like
get the [__] away from me type thing and
it's because they're just by most people
because because they they're scared
they're like wait what they're like get
away from me they're like they're like
leave me alone and then now it's a
little different now when I go people
like stare at me because they want me to
turn around and say something to them
now but
I learned my lesson a few times never to
do that in public because I've learned
like private is
private I guess and that yeah I didn't
want Brian on my reading because if my
uncle Pax can do I know I was going to
cry yeah
you're emotional and but but I also you
know it is something private but then
also like I knew you had this you know
skill set yeah so right when I walked
down like oh man he's probably like hey
Uncle Pax has quit jacking off in the
shower hey
yeah but I'm when you met your girl
where you're like hey uh listen my
name's Jonathan your grandma told me I
should come over
your grandmother approved no I've had
like horrible experiences before like I
caught girlfriends cheating on me from
this no I swear God what yeah so I got
visions of that you just you don't have
eternal he's Netflix and chill he's like
oh I see a big black just you're not
gonna like this I see a giant black guy
just railing I mean it's pretty hot
so much Tyrone do you know what Tyrone
let me give me your phone yeah it should
be screwed dude yeah I mean it was
Tyrone is a really racist
his name could have been mark
no it was kind of similar to that
actually
yeah
you're [__]
[__] I wrote
[Applause]
yeah I was literally laying with her in
bed watching TV and then her grandfather
was coming through and I was like
ignoring it and then the name Frank kept
coming up
Frank yeah and I was and I turned her up
Italian yeah right and I was like who's
Frank and she turned white like a ghost
and I was like all right this is not
good and I was like I was like what's
going on an assist from the grandpa yeah
and she said she's a [__] yeah
and Frank Frank yeah and then she like
kind of admitted to me I get I guess
because she was so like rattled by it
she took out her phone and she's like my
ex was is Frank and we were just I've
been playing a few months oh wow and she
was like I saw him like last night and I
was like all right you gotta go like one
of those things like it's crazy you
gotta go yeah it's crazy yeah so I need
you to sweep my wife's phone yeah just
give me but with her um
I didn't tell her right away I didn't
tell her right away I um I had like
experiences with people that were like
you know very different with it so I
waited and waited and then when I knew
it was going to be very serious with us
I told her and it looked like she got
hit by a bat or something and she's like
prove it like she literally was just
like prove it so
I I said
um
I brought in a family member that her
family has never spoken about and I've
been dating her for almost three years
and they still don't speak about this
person because of how they passed and
things like that because they're
religious and
and whatever and
she was just like pouring tears and like
for two hours she was just staring at me
and I could feel her I'm like watching
that's a lot it's a lot I'm like
watching TV and I could feel her like on
the couch right there just like staring
through me demon yeah I was like I was
like are we good and like you know
Hold Your Hand
s she was like
wait what like that she kept going like
wait I don't understand this it's not
yeah your name you need a you need an
oracle's name you need something like I
know you know
because even though I'm open-minded you
know mediums and all that stuff I'm
super into ghosts and all that stuff
yeah I went in I was like let's go to
this [__] and then when he's going
like oh my God I'm telling you the stuff
he was doing and Brian's still suspect
which is the way he is 60. but I think
57 it could be good for you guys to do
it I don't know if you're down for it
but I am have you ever have you ever
read somebody though where you didn't
get anything or you read them wrong so
knock on wood um I haven't I I I will
say about reading them wrong was they
would come to me with an expectation of
hearing from one person and then another
person would come through so then they
would be like from their perspective
they'd be like this reading is point
like pointless to me they're like I
wanted to hear from this person but this
person came in and like when he was
doing mine my my wife's uh Grandma came
I was like can you can you
[Laughter]
no
uh I'm very selfish this isn't about you
right now uh Uncle Pax push her to the
side
no espanol by the way I met you once
okay look at John went I want to know
about my own Uncle Pax and John went I'm
getting something uh p uh yeah no he
didn't ask anything yeah nothing
it's wild yeah but yeah yeah my my
girl's Grandma's like if you could just
sit in about you right now save it
yeah it's amazing man thank you it's
amazing thank you is it is it if you
could go back and do it if you could
give yourself this Talent would you do
it still
it's a lot right yeah I I think I would
but I think I'd go about like a very
different way than I did it
I was like really nervous like I played
college lacrosse and stuff I played at
three schools I was a little bit of um a
partier but um I started at Community
College and I did well and then I went
Upstate I don't know if you guys know
LaCrosse or whatever I know Lacrosse oh
you do you played oh okay so he played
in college right yeah okay so I went to
SUNY court court Cortland yeah and then
I went to Farmingdale State College
after and
so I had a little too much fun Upstate
yeah good lacrosse yeah especially at
Cortland yeah it was I I committed to
UMass Amherst and then when they sent me
the workout program in the summer I was
like get me the hell out of here yeah I
was like I did not expect it like you
know I did not I was like I want to
enjoy College
and then when I went Upstate it was like
a division one program I was having like
these workouts and film and then
practice cortland's real deal yeah and
we were playing like Syracuse and then
we were playing like you know Albany and
then the Iroquois national team and like
all this stuff and I was like I did not
sign up for this like but it was such a
good experience that
you know then I went to to Farmingdale
because of coaches that went there I
followed coaches but but anyway I was
afraid to tell them because I was like
I'm in a locker room with these guys
every day and I hear how they are and I
was like for me to tell them like I was
like scared but then they all once they
found out they're like the most
supportive people ever but I think it
was just my perception of like locker
room dudes you mean you you were feeling
this it's almost like it's like a secret
you had yeah it was it would be very
weird to have a friend so if you're all
hanging out and your buddy goes guys ah
I talked to the dead yeah no that's how
everybody'd be like well you can't hang
out with me anymore because you're crazy
especially college kids yeah don't
forget up to your coach like hey man I'm
down to do this Sprint but you have my
third string dude yeah he's like how do
you know like I know yeah I know I don't
need to run this is high yeah no I
didn't tell him until I was like 25 26
like I waited so you wish you would have
I wish I would have to come out earlier
it's fair to say come out yeah yeah yeah
I I wish I kind of like told them way or
earlier because they were supportive but
I think at that time you know just
hearing them talk about stuff like in
the locker room like I'm saying I'm like
they would have been like the [__] is
wrong with this kid like yeah so the
only thing you would have changed is you
would have said something earlier yeah I
would have changed that and I probably
would have told my family like my
extended family earlier on because it
caused riffs within my family because
one side is pretty religious one is not
and the side that was pretty religious
they're like like why are you
encouraging you know to do this like
stop and I wish I didn't like
you know I really really messed me up so
I wish I didn't let it mess me up well
the Old Testament talks about mediums
and psychics and and tells the
Israelites basically to kill them right
you know yeah yeah you know it's like
that that would be death by stoning yeah
so so if you're religious you're steeped
in that sort of exactly and and that's
why I was very kind of like I just wish
I didn't care so much because I knew
they wouldn't have done anything but led
you down this road you're good now and
then you also who knows you probably
wouldn't have been the NYPD you know at
least having that background you know
their process which I'm sure helped you
out helped me out a lot and that's how I
I was able to connect with other people
within there to do it and the homicide
and Cold Case unit and stuff I just knew
people that knew people that were in it
and those units are like the cold case
unit is like tiny it's like 16 people
it's not a big unit yeah there's not a
lot of incentive right yeah there's none
because they work on a case and there's
nothing against them and then they can't
get enough evidence in a certain amount
of time and then like all right no
resources yeah onto the other 10
we'll just do it again so make sure I'm
right man
no because don't cops nowadays have all
the cameras and they can tie them all
together yeah now they have the body
cams on them that they can but no I'm
saying when somebody kills somebody
getting away like you can just follow
the cameras Oh yeah yeah constantly on
camera yes yep
whoa yeah
that's crazy yeah it's it's nuts that's
I I'm amazed yeah 15 I mean not terrible
well just with all the cameras like like
yeah well we're always yeah everybody's
on camera security everywhere yeah you
know what I mean and ring doorbells and
dash cams and those are huge I I did a
case in Ohio where I told them about
someone who did it with one of the
police departments and they went on the
neighbor's ring and they saw the license
plate yeah when the body was thrown and
they connected to the person that I was
saying that's how that you know that
Murdoch trial yeah yeah thing on it so
you know the the red that's a
fascinating I never trust redheads but
that redhead he killed the why we know
this can't trust him but yeah the
redhead killed his son and the wife yeah
there was no evidence zero evidence it
looked like he was gonna get away with
it you know what got him caught and cell
phone
see so but not but not from him from his
wife or his kid they could they can
improve anything with that it was a
buddy of his sons was there at the same
time he was there and he was filming the
dog because they're out in the kennels
we commit the murders and you hear that
Alex Murdoch's voice go bustered call
the wife bust in the sun Buster whatever
Mary yeah get down here and they could
look at the time code and see it was
like 10 minutes after they got murdered
otherwise he would have gotten away with
it he would have got away with it why
because he's just like there's no
evidence there's nothing didn't have
anything right and then his whole Alibi
was think about his little Alibi was I
was at my mom's house
I didn't know why he killed uh flat
Financial struggle yeah he he was he was
laundering a lot of money and he was
some money issues and then his son uh
murdered someone on a boat by accident
he got hammered and murdered a a girl on
a boat and they were gonna come for the
Sun but he was laundering and stealing
all this money he was worried that his
son his case would highlight all the
family and bring the family down I don't
know why he killed the wife
yeah so the son that killed the girl he
killed he killed him he shot he blew his
brains out oh my
what yep terrible person yeah there are
some there are some Psychopaths I can't
conceive of it there are some people
that are so bad that even their own
children are just objects yeah yeah and
that's kind of how it was with Rex right
his his daughter and everyone like they
had no idea what was going they never do
well they never do well that's like the
BTK killer like he was like church in
the church I just I just recently heard
about that case I never heard about that
bro like I'm into serial killers that
one I'll stay away from that one because
it involves kids and yeah murdering
sisters in front of Brothers like little
kids I heard he was like taunting people
or something yeah torch them and then
taunt them in front of them that's when
I that when it's the kids involved I
step back yeah yeah like The Night
Stalker killing Graham and stuff I'm all
in uh Dahmer killing gay guys sign me up
you know Ted Bundy doing his thing cool
but as soon as they go to the kids I'm
out I can't do the kids
yeah I'm out in general yes that's
fascinating but when they do kids it's
so dark yeah that's what I can't do it
and like Idaho four too that was battle
four that one's interesting that one is
not I got a call for that one too I was
just gonna ask you that yeah you know
about the Idaho four right oh yeah yeah
and that was the first case I was like I
don't want to be a part of because when
they were explaining things after I
spoke to them they were saying that this
this person would like could essentially
drive to my house in a second and he's
so smart and Brilliant that like he
could like get to me within an hour
right because he was untraceable yeah
from Philly and then he also majored in
criminology just to learn how to get
away with them yeah but he did a lot of
dumb [__] he did do a lot like
there like what are you doing dude he
had like a like a notebook I heard where
he would have like potato and then he
would have all these different cases and
he would say like what they did right
and wrong in the cases and then he was
trying to perfect like a perfect like
serial killing like moment
there was a Facebook group for that
those murders he would get on there
that's how they caught him they would
get on there and give away evidence that
the detectives were like oh we didn't
announce as a public who is this guy
they looked into it right that's one of
the reasons he'd be a suspect because he
was saying stuff on there that's not
common knowledge and like who the [__]
is this guy yeah it was like a Reddit
thread too or something he's like going
deep into Reddit and like dude he looks
evil too yeah my God yeah he was like
taunting them like when he even got
arrested I thought that was like he was
yeah because they're emails I think yeah
at the murder scene when you know when
the cops were on the scene people were
coming up he drove up yeah I was like in
the crowd like stairs of course of
course terrible human being got off on
it just got off on you know creating
destruction and watching his own work
yeah like that's so there's a there was
a sociopath who used to that so I knew a
lawyer who um I do know a lawyer whose
client he had this kid came from a
really wealthy family super wealthy he
would start fires
and then he would dress up like a
fireman and direct the traffic around
the fire
so he would stand there and watch all
the traffic have to stop because there
was a fire and he'd go you guys go this
way this way and they would always catch
him because they'd go go see if uh
and they'd see him they go hey [__] face
hey but dumbass but just be a licensed
flyer no I know he wanted to create no
it wasn't that he liked to create the
havoc and then watch
people freak out over it there was
another guy who used to do this to um he
would light male uh he would uh like
find post offices and light them on fire
and he would just be on the hit see him
down the street you know how they caught
the Green River Killer no I believe this
is how uh they said you'll find him
masturbating
uh at one of the sites so they'd find
the body and they go go find go look at
where there's a car there and you'll
find him masturbating there and that's
how they caught him he would masturbate
to to that so but I think they caught
him because because he was masturbating
his DNA was found he wasn't caught in
the car apparently they one of the guys
I don't know if it was him but they he
was killing women by a river and this
Richard Walter I think FBI profiler said
you'll find him you'll find him jerking
off probably in his car oh my God so he
would look he would relive the fantasy
at where he did a lot of them do or they
take tokens or Jesus Christ
some darts the people at the weirdest
darkest [__] because there's this
there's this thing about there's another
fetish where people break into houses
and take shits in the person's house
yeah or masturbate in the closet while
somebody's home and it's the tension of
that and then they get out there's a lot
of weird [__] we're just people are
afraid freaks so I think we have people
like you man to sniff them out before
they get going yeah yeah that'd be a
weird thing yeah he's taking a [__] in
the closet yeah a match oh my God you
know
um it's really interesting though that's
a heavy that's great yeah I think it's
so cool man will you be down for a read
sure
we appreciate it brother dude thank you
for having me guys thank you and I
appreciate the read man it's great it's
really cool I really recommend it if
people want to get that done I don't
know if you're down to give out some
details but I'm sure some people will be
interested yeah um you just go to my
social media Jonathan Mark medium that's
where all my stuff is
and
um just book a reading through through
an email yeah pretty standard not the
mark medium
that's great what do you call call her
daddy yep
and that's Gabby's mom we were just like
we were allowed to post it so we both
posted the picture that's her mom right
there yeah yeah
she's I have to be honest she's amazing
like how she's like like how she handled
it and what she's doing with that is
amazing like God bless her man yeah
she's gone through the worst thing you
can imagine yep and so when you have a
kid get a cam picture don't want to no
me neither all right brother we
appreciate you man thank you so much
thanks buddy of course